there's a side quest in the original
mass effect where you must collect
16 ancient asari writings which you can
do by scanning planets
as well as landing on uncharted worlds
and searching for them
it's an awful collection task quest
deathly boring to do even with a guide
the reward isn't even all that great
being nothing but some
measly experience points the saving
grace being that because the whole thing
is so meaningless you can skip it
without fear
of missing out however in mass effect 3
there is a small
side quest on the citadel for shepherd
stan
conrad verner turns out that before
conrad devoted his life to worshiping
the commander
he wrote a doctoral dissertation on
xenotechnology and dark energy
integration
and can help shepherd obtain some
ancient tech
if you collected 10 of the 16 ancient
asari writings back in mass effect 1
along with a few other optional side
quests you'll get some special dialogue
as well as a plus 5 bonus to your war
assets
this is one of those rare moments that
most players
didn't fully experience in their mass
effect trilogy play through
strange or unique outcomes that require
you to do something either
really obscure to get or because you
made choices in the past that fall
in between the cracks of the series
morality system
most players tend to play a pure paragon
or renegade playthrough but if you mix
and match you'll get some pretty
interesting consequences in this video
i'm gonna go through a few of my
favorite rare
mass effect outcomes originally this
video was
really long so if you have other moments
you'd like to see
or have your own favorites drop them in
the comments below
or like this video and subscribe so we
know you want to see
more it goes without saying that this
video contains spoilers for the whole
series
except andromeda cause i don't talk
about that game
mass effect may be all about choice but
some things are
predestined some characters won't make
it to the end
no matter what decisions you make the
first and most heartbreaking loss in
mass effect 3
is solarian scientist morden solus
who is doomed to either sacrifice
himself to cure the genophage
or betrayed by shepard and shot in the
back
either way morden has to die or does he
yes morton can live and you might be
thinking
well that sounds like the best situation
i love morton
and i would like him to live but the
reality is to get this outcome you
actually have to [ __ ] up
really badly mistake number one you
killed rex back on vermeyer
which means his blood brother reeve is
in charge of clan erdnaught
reeve is both stupid and bloodthirsty
and a future with him in charge of the
krogan
may very well lead to another krogan
rebellion
but that's okay because with eve at his
side
she can help guide him in the right
direction mistake number two
you didn't save malen's research data in
mass effect 2 and eve is now
dead or mistake 2.5 eve dies because you
didn't stop the bomb
onto chanka with eve not around to keep
reeve in check
shepard now has a pretty compelling case
as to why it's not a good idea
to save the krogan right now this is
enough to convince morton
who then fakes his death so reef thinks
he died
curing the genophage he will then assist
in building the crucible
bringing you a small bonus to your war
assets and sending shepard a nice little
thank you email
you even get a final goodbye with him on
earth
but as far as everyone else is concerned
morton is dead
was his survival worth the genocide of a
whole species
i'll leave that up to you another tragic
death in mass effect 3
is thane who dies at the hands of series
edge lord kai
lang as he's saving the solarian
councilor sorry if i just got your hopes
up but
there is no way around this one if thane
is alive in mass effect 3 he
is fated to die here but what happens if
thane
isn't in mass effect 3 what happens to
the salarian counselor
well remember captain kirihei from mass
effect 1 our
influence stopped the rachni but before
that
we held the line our influence stopped
the krogan
but before that we held the line
our influence will stop staring
in the battle today we will hold the
line
yeah that guy you actually meet him
briefly on sir kesh
now major kira hay congrats on the
promotion buddy
for most players this is just a nice
little nod to the character
but for those that didn't have thane
around it's actually a clever
reintroduction and
setup because you guessed it kirhay
shows up in thane's place and saves the
counselor
you held the line good buddy of course
kira hate can actually
die all the way back on vermire if
shepard chooses not to help the solarian
squad by turning off a couple defenses
if that's the case well the counselor
just
dies whoops if this happens udina will
actually use doctored security footage
to make it look like shepard was the one
to kill them
making it harder to convince ashley or
kaidan
speaking of let's touch on the fate of
another pair of squad members
ashley and cayden whose roles are
largely identical in mass effect 2 and 3
depending on who you saved for
simplicity we will refer to them
as the vermier survivor their story
culminates during udina's attempted coup
of the citadel council there is a hidden
score
based on a number of factors that will
determine the outcome such as
romance saving the council on mass
effect 1 and how you've interacted
with them in mass effect 3. if you get a
positive score you can convince them of
uttina's betrayal and then get the
option to have them join you on the
normandy for the rest of the game
if you end up with a negative score you
can't convince them and they'll
get shot by either shepherd or one of
your squad mates
brutal there is however a rare third
outcome
it is possible to have a high enough
score to persuade the vermier survivor
to
back off during the confrontation with
udina while simultaneously still having
a broken relationship with them
this means they will straight up refuse
shepard's offer to join the normandy
and can't be a squadmate for the rest of
the game and so i respectfully decline
i didn't even know this could happen
until very recently
which just goes to show how much work
and thought the devs really did put into
these games
okay why don't we take a break from all
the death and sadness and
talk about a more fun lighthearted
moment in mass effect 1.
one of the required missions of the game
is to head to the prothean dig site on
the planet of
thuram and find dr liara tasoni
most players will head to thuram first
as it's what the game recommends and
you'll
want liar early if you're interested in
romancing her
but you don't have to you can wait and
wait
and wait in fact you can wait all the
way until the end of the game when there
is
nothing else to do but save liara
when you finally show up it turns out
she's been trapped in the prothean
security bubble this whole time
and is losing her goddamn mind you'll
get a unique conversation where liara
believes
shepherd is a hallucination followed by
a equally hilarious scene back on the
normandy
where you inform liara that the plot of
the entire game
basically happened without her sovereign
the cipher a prothean beacon i
i'm sorry this is all a bit overwhelming
i just
i need a moment to collect myself
as we've made pretty clear so far in
this video party member death is a
pretty major part of the mass effect
trilogy in mass effect 3 not only can
many of the major characters die
but often shepard is the one who kills
them
which makes a renegade playthrough
pretty brutal
most of this friend murder happens in
cutscenes but there are several you can
kill in
combat the first being everyone's
favorite space psychopath
jack after parting ways with shepard
jack becomes a teacher
at grissom academy a school for gifted
biotics
a major side mission in the game
involves rescuing jack and her students
from
cerberus but it is possible to ignore it
in mass effect 3 if you carry on with
the main story you'll get locked out of
side content as time moves forward
and this is taken into account as jack
and her students are kidnapped by
cerberus when storming the elusive man's
base near the end of the game you'll
come across a special recording of jack
being tortured
further in you'll find jack now
brainwashed into a phantom
and you'll have to put her down along
the same vein as jack
is legion it is possible to give up
legion's body to cerberus back in mass
effect 2
a choice absolutely nobody made because
who is going to give up the chance at a
death party member well
if you did cerberus will indeed have
kept the body and experimented on them
the empty shell that was once legion
shows up as a special enemy type in the
cerberus base the same room where
phantom jack
also appears the final party member to
talk about is
morith one of samara's ardoc yakshi
daughters
who you can side with in mass effect 2.
morith was always a
limited party member she pretends to be
samara for the rest of mass effect 2 as
to not arouse suspicion
which basically means she says all the
things samara does
outside of a few small moments with her
being
so limited in mass effect 2 it's
disappointing but not at all surprising
that she doesn't make a proper
appearance in mass effect 3.
shepard gets an email from her but
that's about it
however at some point in the game morith
was found by the reapers and turned into
a banshee
in the final battle on earth morith will
appear she behaves just like any other
banshee
and gets no special dialogue everybody
is horny for somebody in mass effect and
while bioware does his best to make your
dreams a reality there are some party
members you just can't romance
two of those were military beefcake
james vega
and prothean sad boy javik which a vocal
group of fans were pretty disappointed
with javik makes
total sense to me he's the last of an
ancient alien species with a really hot
voice
he can throw me out of an airlock any
day james on the other hand
well he's not for me but he is voiced by
freddie prince jr
aka the iron bull in dragon age so i
sort of get it
bioware must have heard the fans cries
because they added two hidden romance
paths in the citadel dlc
during the big party if shepard doesn't
have a romance partner and makes certain
dialogue choices
they will wake up the next morning
having slept with either james
or javik
it turns out there is one thing
primitives are good at
not a word
the javik scene is played as a joke but
the james one
i find genuinely creepy shepard can make
several advances on james throughout the
game but he always turns her down
making it pretty clear he's not
interested
yet in the citadel dlc shepherd
eventually resorts to getting james
drunk enough so that he'll sleep with
her
to cap the whole thing off they'll wake
up in the morning and he sounds like he
regrets it even
happened like what the [ __ ] bioware i
don't think this is what fans had in
mind
if the genders in this situation were
reversed this would have
never made it into the game okay i don't
want to end this video on such a
awkward downer so let's go back to the
fun stuff
killing squad mates during the previous
section where the
bad thing happened i mentioned the
citadel dlc
and the big party you can throw at the
end citadel was the final content made
for the original trilogy
as such the whole thing is one massive
celebration of its characters
bioware went all out bringing back the
whole cast
and stuffing in as many in-jokes as
possible
as a final to these beloved characters
you couldn't ask for anything better
but the thing is citadel's charm is
dependent on these characters
and what happens if none of them are
alive
well that's what my co-worker jake
decker and i went on a journey to find
out
in our series the saddest party on the
citadel
a multi-part let's play where we planned
out the murder of all of our squad mates
in order to get the fewest number of
characters possible
available for the party turns out there
are three party members that you can't
kill
in the whole series liara james
and edie that's it this is a bit
different from everything else we've
been talking about
there is an extra dialogue or a new
scene the party goes on
exactly the same except nobody is
present
i don't think bioware expected anyone to
actually play the game this way
but i love that as possible it's the
ultimate example of what happens when
you push this series emphasis on player
choice
to its limits you get a sad shepherd
throwing a rubbish party
for the only few people left they
haven't gotten killed
so as i said up front if you've got any
rare outcomes you'd love us to see
featured
in a future video let me know in the
comments below
if you like mass effect and if you made
it through this video it seems like you
do
make sure to stick around we've got
plenty of it coming up on the channel
so
you